um i think this is a good idea and i
know that there are people who say well
you know david their
impetus for wanting to do this is
different than ours might be
i don't really care i i it's the right
thing to do and i support doing it
yeah absolutely and there are some
people who are saying that republicans
are trying to outflank democrats on this
issue which is an argument i don't think
you can really make because remember the
house passed a bill to full-on legalize
marijuana i believe it was on party
lines or mostly along party lines
but democrats are at least in the house
pushing for full-on legalization this
bill would just be decriminalization but
at the same time if this is the bill
that gets passed through the house and
the senate actually decides to take it
up then that would be a good thing right
because it would show that there's
actually republican support for this and
then maybe you can bring across 10
republican senators
to support this and then ultimately
the democrats will join them and maybe
you can get this on president biden's
desk and he could sign it into law